bom dia
deixa eu só vir aqui e se contradisse a
antes de mais nada eu queria dizer que
estou muito feliz de estar com vocês
aqui hoje é também um pouco tensa porque
eu tenho o hábito de falar muito de
detalhar muitas histórias que conto e
hoje vou ter que ser super o objetivo
final eu tenho 18 minutos para falar o
que eu me propus a trazer aqui pra vocês
hoje eu sou a michelle eu sou
publicitária de formação eu trabalhei um
bom tempo em agências de propaganda no
rio grande do sul até é a tropeçar uma
perestroika pela minha frente
a perestroika uma escola de criatividade
eu fui parar na perestroika para ser
gestora do business no rio grande do sul
e obviamente por ser uma escola eu
acabei me envolvendo muito com a
educação com uma educação diferente de
tudo que eu conhecia uma educação
inspiradora com educação emotiva e
comecei a me apaixonar por esse negócio
chamado educação e junto com a
perestroika no começo do ano passado de
2013 eu fui nenhum outro negócio que se
chama escolher o que é uma consultoria
em processos de aprendizado é uma
consultoria que busca levar uma visão
mais criativa mais inovadora mais
contemporânea para instituições de
ensino ea gente como empresa perestroika
tem um propósito na a gente quer
transformar o mundo num lugar mais
criativo sensível subversivo e do bem ea
gente acredita que através da educação é
possível a gente fazer isso antes de
entrar nessa nossa visão de educação que
é o que eu vou falar pra vocês aqui hoje
eu gostaria só de contextualizar um
pouco o cenário onde a nossa educação de
hoje foi constituída a educação que a
gente vive hoje e essa foto aqui ela
representa bem esse cenário que é uma
foto da revolução industrial
nesse momento aqui a sociedade estava
vivendo uma adaptação para um processo
de linha de produção de linha de
montagem um processo onde a sociedade
tenha que se adaptar um modelo linear a
um modelo reprodutiva o modelo era
completamente inovador para a época
nessa linha
montagem quem operava essa linha de
montagem em 80% a mão de obra humana
eram pessoas que operavam o que
acontecia é que essas pessoas não
estavam preparadas para operar nessas
linhas de montagem é o que a revolução
industrial preciso fazer a revolução
industrial preciso criar uma fábrica que
preparasse que gerasse essas pessoas
para trabalhar dentro da fábrica porque
essas pessoas não estavam preparadas e
essa fábrica que preparava pessoas para
trabalharem nas fábricas se chamava
escola então foi nesse contexto nesse
cenário que a escola pública a escola
gratuita a escola massiva surgiu e aí a
gente quando para avaliar e comparar
algumas algumas características fabris
com o ambiente escolar
a gente começa a achar várias coisas
similares na é o horário de entrar e
sair
apitos que chamam a hora de entrar e
sair os intervalos uniformização todo
mundo tem o mesmo modelo de vestir é
hierarquia e subordinação não é o
professor eo aluno é áreas desconectadas
da matemática uma coisa física outra
coisa química outra coisa
padronização na avaliação é uma prova
para todos igual à pouca oportunidade de
escolha ou divergência você tem essa
matéria você vai aprender isso agora né
e crescimento linear
eu vou da primeira para a segunda para
terceira como é um ambiente fabril ea
produção em linha de montagem faz
sentido isso né
e se a gente olha para uma escola de
hoje ela continua produzindo um modelo
muito similar a isso aqui é até hoje é
uma escola tradicional né
e se a gente vai olhar pro modelo que
representa a nossa sociedade atual
ela tem muito mais a ver com essa imagem
isso é uma fotografia da internet onde
há esse como nesse contexto aqui a gente
tem uma sociedade estruturada de maneira
lá nada linear totalmente randômica
totalmente imprevisível e quando a gente
olha isso aqui a gente fica pensando pô
será que a educação de hoje está
adaptada para esse modelo de mundo
esse já estava vendo um documentário que
falava assim ah se você pegar um médico
de 200 anos atrás e colocar numa sala de
cirurgia de hoje provavelmente esse
médico não entendo nem que instrumentos
são aqueles procurar se você for pegar
um professor de 200 anos atrás e colocar
numa sala de aula tradicional de hoje
provavelmente ele vai sentir bastante
familiarizado com aquele ambiente ea a
gente acredita que a educação precisa
mudar ea gente como a escola se sente
super desconfortável de olhar para esse
cenário né
então a gente começou a observar novas
tendências novos movimentos educacionais
fez um estudo sobre isso e eu vou
apresentar para vocês agora um compilado
de de que tendências são essas da
educação contemporânea é antes de entrar
eu queria fazer um aviso sabe aqueles
avisos adiantar é no elevador que este é
um conteúdo autoral é algo que a gente
acredita não há uma verdade absoluta não
a uma invenção da roda
são movimentos educacionais movimentos
de aprendizado que a gente percebeu e
que a gente dividiu é por clusters para
nos ajudar a identificar esses
movimentos e poder levar isso pra
instituições que aplicam algum tipo de
processo de aprendizado
certo a primeira tendência da educação
contemporânea são oito tendências que
vão apresentar a vocês e tecnologia
tecnologia é bastante óbvio na
tecnologia é uma tendência pró
absolutamente tudo na vida para qualquer
área é de desenvolvimento e quando falo
em tecnologia eu tô levando falando sim
levar hardware para dentro de sala de
aula eu tô falando em modelos é de
educação à distância eu tô falando em
quadros interativos eu tô falando em
aplicativos de aprendizado eu tô falando
em modelos como pequena queda me como
descomplica como o curso era é eu tô
falando de ao invés da gente enxergar o
celular como alguém que está competindo
com a gente e com os alunos dentro de
sala de aula a gente enxergar o celular
talvez como aliado em alguns momentos na
será que a gente não pode olhar para
essa plataforma e uma maneira de passar
o conteúdo através dela do que enxergava
como inimigo a gente acredita que sim
é a segunda tendência de
descentralização
quando eu tô falando descentralização
tem muito a ver obviamente com a
tecnologia porque a partir do momento
que a internet invadiu a casa das
pessoas
os alunos têm acesso absolutamente
qualquer tipo de informação essa é a
verdadeira sala de aula deles né
o professor deixa de ser o único
detentor do conteúdo ea partir do
momento que ele não é mais o único
detentor do conteúdo ele passa a agir
muito mais como o orquestrador que deixa
emergir a inteligência coletiva na ele
vai conduzindo dentro de sala de aula
para que os alunos ajudem a construir o
conteúdo ea gente acredita que só uma
maneira muito mais fluida e talvez até
mais natural ano atualmente de se fazer
energia é como exemplo de escolas que já
aplica um modelo de centralizado eu
acredito que minha brincadeira que vem
falar hoje pra vocês têm um modelo que
tem a ver com isso onde existe a
construção em grupo movimentos que eu
acho que o pessoal tá aí eu vi alguma
coisa assim do arroz tem tem a ver com
isso que fazem a construção coletiva e
acho que são coisas que a gente pode
levar o que eu estou falando aqui desses
movimentos tá
não que a que precise mudar
completamente para um deles na a a gente
vai pegando um pouquinho de cada um e
aplicando da melhor maneira possível é
personalização quando fala em
personalização eu falo em respeitar a
diversidade em respeitar a
individualidade a forma como cada
indivíduo o processo o aprendizado na
talvez eu michelle processo o
aprendizado melhor maneira expositivas
uma aula expositiva vez o joão processo
o aprendizado melhor fazendo atividades
lamba duna mexendo em equipamento talvez
a maioria aprendam melhor através de
jogos e talvez eu aprenda melhores
positivo matemática mas portuguesa eu
aprendo melhora através de jogos então
não existe uma única a fórmula e quando
a gente fala em personalização é
justamente respeitar a diversidade
respeitar a forma como cada indivíduo
processo aprendizado
existe uma escola nos estados unidos que
chama scofano que trabalha nesse modelo
de personalização eles criaram um álbum
timo que calcula testes e o aluno chega
na escola é vai fazer um teste antes de
selar de álgebra e ele vai para um
conteúdo expositivo e aí no final ele
faz um tacho e hitachi vai lá e
alimentos algoritmo e aí olha você não
foi também amanhã você entra na sala b
quando ele entra na sala b ele vai
aprender através de algum jogo e por
agora ele foi melhor avaliado e assim
vai personalizando educação
de acordo com que cada indivíduo precisa
storytelling quando foi o storytelling
eu tô falando sobre condução através de
uma narrativa de contar histórias de
trazer o conteúdo de uma forma mais
lúdica que tem a ver muito com a técnica
de storytelling quando eu tenho um
conteúdo para passar
eu vejo qual é a grande o grande
objetivo desse conteúdo a moral da
história e vou deixando com informações
técnicas que alimentam aquele conteúdo e
com histórias que tornam aquele conteúdo
mais emotivo essa foto aqui ela é da
sala de aula de um professor que é nosso
parceiro ricardo dias
ele dá uma escola pública de londres e
ele aplica um currículo criativo que
isso significa
junto com os alunos eles eles escolhem o
tema que vai ser trabalhado dentro de
sala de aula então por exemplo ele
escolhia o tema trabalhado vencer
fábrica de chocolate
eles interligam todas as disciplinas
dentro daquele conteúdo não existe
separação de disciplina
então eles falam ah ah ah pra falar de
matemática na fábrica de chocolate eles
fazem o processo de a comprar os
chocolates e fazer com que a conta que
sairia isso pra vender na moeda de troca
química a com derrete chocolate pra
botar forminha quando congelo chocolate
qual é o processo de crime está
acontecendo e é descentralizado porque
os alunos vão fazendo o processo da
fábrica eo professor vai passando e vai
orientando game ficação significação há
uma tendência que com certeza vai além
da educação a tendência de vida
atualmente saiu uma pesquisa do e que
fala que até 2020 80% da nossa vida vai
ser verificada e quando eu falo ans e
dignificado o processo de aprendizado
significado tem a ver
uma lógica de games né a lógica de games
a a lógica de engajamento é de na
primeira fase
você vai lá e aprendi de um chutinho
porque na segunda fase você vai precisar
esse chutinho pra passar um obstáculo e
na terceira fase você vai precisar um
chutinho soquinho e assim você vai
alimentando engajam do usuário porque
ele vai sentindo preparado pra iaiá até
à próxima fase
e isso pode ser feito também em processo
de aprendizado em jogos de aprendizado
existe uma uma é a iniciativa em nova
york que chama instituto play que
desenvolveu um projeto para uma escola
pública de nova york onde 100% do
processo de aprendizado é dignificado
100% qualquer disciplina e além de
significado os alunos são incentivados a
produzir em games está a alimentar o
conteúdo da escola também desde a
escolarização antes escolarização tem a
ver com uma educação mais autônoma na
tem a ver com a aprender fora do
ambiente da escola tradicional não é
deixar de buscar o conhecimento ou
deixar de buscar saber é buscar em
outros ambientes têm a ver com
movimentos como high school em que esse
menino aqui tem uma técnica incrível que
fala sobre isso nada tem a ver com
hackear raqa não só aqui a partir de
computadores hackear a educação é um
interesso é puro snowboard como era o
caso dele ele foi hackear e processar o
aprendizado através daquilo que
interessa a ele porque através do
quebrar essa porque o que me interessa
me despertar mais curiosidade que me
interessa
vai tocar mais vai envolver mais e eu
vou buscar aprender e saber mais sobre
isso tem uma iniciativa que chama um
colégio que está vindo para o brasil
acho que agora a partir de agosto que
que aplica um pra um projeto de um ano
que fala sobre aprender a aprender como
é que eu monto o meu próprio processo de
aprendizado como é que eu aprendo a
aprender é escola mais vida à escola
mais vida tem a ver com levar conteúdos
do cotidiano pra vida dentro da escola
ou op a conteúdos da escola e associar
com coisas é da vida porque a gente não
pode aprender na escola sobre
empreendedorismo
criatividade sobre felicidade sobre como
ser um bom amigo né quem é que disse que
esses não esses não são conteúdos
importantes para a gente ouve na escola
tem a ver também com buscar conteúdos da
escola e associar com coisas da vida
porque quando eu for uma aula de física
sobre leis da física eu não posso levar
os alunos para uma pista de skate ea a
partir dos movimentos de skate falar
sobre quem regras da física estão
acontecendo será que isso não vai fazer
mais sentido e gerar uma associação que
corresponde a algo que faz sentido na
vida do aluno na existe uma escola que
aplica algo semelhante é isso que até
essa foto que a mostra que é a esquete
tam é uma escola do afeganistão onde
dois australianos montaram aulas de
skate lá e começaram a perceber que
essas aulas estavam dando lições de
cidadania para esses alunos na andar de
skate passa uma sensação de segurança e
e essa segurança é se essa coletividade
que eles tinham que interpretar
participando ale era uma aula que era
super necessário num ambiente de um país
que é super repressor e aí eles
começaram a completar e hoje o projeto
tem iniciativas em várias cidades
é daquela região bom antes de entrar na
próxima tendência eu queria pedir para
vocês pegarem vendas que tem embaixo das
cadeiras de vocês estão coladas embaixo
das cadeiras de vocês e eu vou precisar
que vocês sejam rápidos e coloquem essas
vendas nos olhos de vocês
quem não tem venda embaixo da cadeira só
fecha os olhos mas por favor fechem os
olhos rapidinho e me ajudem
vamos lá eu queria pedir para vocês
respirarem fundo e que você se
imaginassem uma praia
o ambiente de uma praia
quero que vocês imaginem o cenário de
uma praia que cores que paleta de cores
é só praia tem que cheiro essa praia tem
som vocês escutam nossa praia
podem tirar as vendas ou abrir os olhos
e eu queria perguntar pra vocês quem de
vocês quando eu falei pra imaginar uma
praia enxergou isso aqui é reay a alguém
favor levantavam se alguém chegou isso e
é engraçado porque 99,9 por cento das
vezes que eu aplico esse teste ninguém
enxerga pr haia
e é engraçado porque a escola
tradicional geralmente nos orienta
enxergar terra haia a passar um conteúdo
de uma maneira liminar a passar o
conteúdo de uma maneira pronta a passar
o conteúdo de uma maneira encaixotada e
isso é contra intuitivo não tenho
certeza que a maioria de vocês enxergou
praia algo mais parecido com esse
cenário aqui porque a gente precisa de
histórias a gente precisa de alimento a
gente precisa de emoção e isso tem a ver
com a educação com experiência que a
última tendência educação com
experiência tem a ver com explorar os
cinco sentidos
tem a ver com gerar momentos que se
tornem viáveis na vida dos indivíduos
têm a ver com conectar experiência com
conteúdo né
a aes essa educação com experiência faz
parte do dna da perestroika
então quando a gente fala que a gente
vive a era da experiência porque a gente
não proporciona isso também dentro de
sala de aula não é porque o aluno não
vivencia aquela prática quando a gente
fala de área de experiência a gente fala
de o dia d por exemplo a fazer esse
exercício que eu fiz com vocês aqui de
praia os alunos entram vendados dentro
da sala de aula e quando eles tiram a
venda eles estão dentro de uma praia
porque a gente coloca areia no chão
porque a gente coloca a cadeira de praia
daqui a pouco quando um vendedor de
milho e daqui a pouco todo aquele
ambiente ele entende tá isso é gerar
experiência isso é a era da experiência
e isso para a educação mais emotiva
torna gostoso torna bom pra dentro de
sala de aula
ó e é engraçado aqui curiosamente muitas
vezes quando eu apresento esse conteúdo
pessoas me fazem uma pergunta que é
ilegal michelle muito legal isso mas eu
queria saber qual o modelo vencedor qual
o modelo que eu posso aplicar na minha
escola a partir do ano que vem ea
resposta é super simples não é nenhum
deles e não é nenhum deles porque sou
maluco estão falando um monte de coisa
para vocês que não tem nada a ver não é
nenhum deles porque fazer essa pergunta
é não entender o modelo entender o
contexto é não entender o randômico a
não entender que o que vale é a
diversidade o que vale é a pluralidade é
o conjunto que forma ondas
quanto mais a gente puder aplicar um
pouco de tudo isso precisamos de escolas
que são mais direcionadas
mas quanto mais a gente puder aplicar um
pouco de tudo isso respeitar a
pluralidade respeita à dívida a
individualidade ea personalização do
conteúdo melhor
é a gente acredita que a educação pode
sim ser mais emotiva pode sim ser mais
criativa e que a educação precisa ser
transformada
a gente tem um mandado na perestroika um
bordão que a uva vai lá e faz o que a
gente repete muito ea eu tenho certeza
que hoje no texas mauá vocês vão ter
bastante conteúdo que vai trazer a
inspiração que vai trazer idéias legais
pra vocês insights e eu gostaria de
convidar vocês a não ficarem só na idéia
não ficarem só noite no insight ou
naquele arquivo ponto do aqui ou no
caderninho que vocês estão anotando as
idéias que vocês tiverem aqui eu
gostaria de comprar vocês a irem lá e
fazerem porque eu tenho certeza que o
mundo está precisando de mais gente que
vai lá e faz